[Music]
high-conflict politicians or what I call
wannabe Kings because that's really what
they want they want to take over an
eliminate opposition how they
effectively gain power in an election
and we're not talking about people that
just became dictators from a war or
something we're talking about people
getting elected and what happens is they
put out all this emotional message all
these emotional words and these
emotional words tend to trigger people
into four different groups and I call
this the four way voter split what
happens is they're loving loyalists they
seduced by saying you're wonderful you
and I want the same thing we know and
believe in all of that it's really
calculated because most of these
politicians shift all over politically
to see what works to get them power so
they say to the loving loyalists what
the loving loyalists want to hear and so
the loving loyal is just go
we love this person and then they change
their politics it's alright we're
already in love so that's maybe thirty
percent of people then on the other side
of that they trigger the riled up
resistors and the riled up resistors are
emotionally hooked and they're angry
they don't like this person they see
this person as very dangerous and a
threat to society and we've got to do
something about this person but they're
emotionally engaged as well then there's
the mild moderates and to some extent
they're kind of stuck they don't know
well is this different or is this
politics and they generally view it
through the lens of this is politics so
if they're on our side politically we'll
support them but we don't like the
personality we wish the person would
stop talking so much and if they're on
the other side they go we don't like his
personality but we really don't like his
politics but they're kind of mild
moderate so they're not really
emotionally activated in fact they may
actually
emotionally intimidated because they
don't want to get fired upon by the
verbal tongue-lashing that HCPs are
always putting out but then the fourth
group is the distant chanted dropouts
and these folks feel emotionally pushed
away it's like just leave me out of this
I'm not political I don't want to be
involved and in all the countries where
we see high conflict politicians rising
to leadership there's a huge percent of
people that emotionally drop out and so
they don't need a majority of people
typically they may have forty percent
maybe forty five percent of the vote but
these high conflict politicians rarely
get over fifty percent but because
they're able to divide these other
groups that they push away the
disenchanted dropout so they just don't
vote and the riled up resistors go with
maybe extreme candidates who don't have
a chance and the mild moderate softn
have a candidate that has a chance but
the moderates and the resistors are
opposing each other mostly because the
high conflict politician has divided
them and so what we see over and over
again around the world is they're
getting into power with less than a
majority of people because they're able
to divide this four-way vote or split
[Music]
you